one more thing and that is this
revelation about anonymous remember
anonymous new york times gives this big
op-ed
senior administration official where it
says i'm part of the resistance inside
the trump administration
well this is the guy take a listen
are you aware of who that is
i'm not look and i that was a uh a
parlor game that happened in washington
dc of a lot of folks trying to think of
who that might be i've got my own
thoughts about who that might be but uh
you know we're not you're not president
and i certainly don't want to
i i wear a mask for two things anderson
uh halloweens and uh pandemics so no
so yes miles taylor actually was he's
the chief of staff for dhs
clearly not the high-ranking senior
administration official
molly that the new york times kind of
implied that it was to give that much
space
the new york times over and over used
this anonymous source they ran an
information operation essentially
saying that there was a very very high
level person in the in the trump
administration
possibly mike pence possibly a cabinet
official possibly a high-ranking
ambassador
who had horrible things to say about the
trump administration and it turned out
it was a low-level person
nobody has heard of if they're willing
to lie about their anonymous sources
when it's a really high level
information operation they're running
imagine how much they're lying about all
the other anonymous sources they use day
in
and day out as part of their anti-trump
campaign
miles taylor is a uh a contributor at
another network very quickly harold
you know should he have gotten that much
time the new york times he's a chief of
staff to our department of homeland
security at the time that he wrote that
op-ed incidentally
voters have a lot to take if this is the
best closing argument my friends on the
other side have
joe biden's going to have a good night
next week
all right we'll leave it there when we
come back dan